so this grocery store chain Giant Eagle
is pulling from its shelves bottled
water sourced from a facility near East
Palestine Ohio they say out of an
abundance of caution Giant Eagle has
made the decision to remove all gallon
size or greater Giant Eagle brand Spring
Water Products sourced from salineville
facility that's right near East
Palestine until further notice until we
continue to evaluate ongoing testing and
potential impacts to the spring Source
the water is obviously poisoned this is
not out of an abundance of caution this
is out of the very bare minimum of
caution of course people don't want to
buy it the grocery store chain doesn't
want to be on the hook if people get
poisoned from this stuff so they're
pulling it absolutely right yes this
contradicts what we've been told by the
EPA administrator but look at people's
behavior people's behavior is going to
tell you very often a lot more than
their words are all the liberal
politicians say the water is totally
safe the air is totally safe but they're
not going to show up are they